membrane fluidity is a parameter that
describes the freedom of movement of
proteins and lipids within the cell
membrane membrane fluidity can be
affected by lipid structure and
composition cholesterol content
temperature
lipid structure significantly affects
membrane fluidity because if there are
more unsaturated fatty acid due to the
kink in the structure there would be
less compaction of the overall membrane
and it would be more fluid lipid
composition widely affects the cell
types and the fluidity of the membranes
in them
cholesterol generally acts like a
dynamic glue so at lower concentration
cholesterol decrease the membrane
fluidity but at very high concentration
cholesterol can increase the membrane
fluidity by preventing compaction of the
lipids
then with the increase in temperature
there would be increase in kinetic
energy that that is why membrane becomes
more fluid
membrane fluidity can be studied using a
frap or fluorescence recovery after food
photo bleaching watch the full video to
know more